[موسيقى]
ونحيكم متابعينا الى مناقشه ملفنا الثاني
بعد القاره السمراء رئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
يتجه الى الصين ضمن سياسه جديده هدفها
بناءه علاقات اقتصاديه قويه ومواجهه
تحديات الدوليه ابرزها الحرب في اوكرانيا
زياره تحمل فطايتها رسائل كثيره للتنين
الصيني جاءت عقب توافق فرنسي امريكي على
اعطاء دور لبكين في انهاء حرب اوكرانيا
وبلوغ حل تفاوضى يمنع تزويد روسيا
بالسلاحه مقروء اكد ان الحوار مع الصين
مهم ودعاها الى لاعب دور اكبر في هذا
الملف بسبب علاقتها الوطيده مع روسيا
زياره مقروصا تكون مقسمه على ثلاثه محاور
تشمل القضايا الاستراتيجيه والازمات
الدوليه الى جانب التعاون في مواجهه
التحديات العالميه الكبرى وبناء العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين صحيفه لوفيغاه
الفرنسيه قالت ان ماكرون يريد كبح التقارب
بين الصين وروسيا والحصول على صفقات
لفائده الش الفرنسيه من طرف بكين حيث رافق
ماكرون في هذه الزياره مدراء نحو 60 شركه
فرنسيه ابرزها شركه ايرباص وهنا سيحاول
اقناع الجانب الصيني بفتح ابوابه واسواقه
امام المستثمرين الفرنسيين خصوصا وان
برنامج الزياره الذي جاء تحت شعار الوحده
الاوروبيه شرط اساسي لبناء شراكه متوازنه
مع الصين هدفه دفع وتيره الاستثمار وتعزيز
المبادلات التجاريه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
التضخم يضرب فرنسا وازمه ارتفاع المواد
الاساسيه لا تزال مستمره الحكومه تبحث عن
حلول بسبب ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه
والخدمات القدره الشرائيه للمواطن الفرنسي
باتت مهدده
45% من الاسر الفرنسيه تواجه وضعا معيشيا
صعبا بسبب ضعف القدره الشرائيه رغم
محاولات الحكومه الفرنسيه وضع سقف للاسعار
الا ان خبراء اقتصاديين دقوا ناقوس الخطر
في البلاد المعهد الوطني للاحصاء الفرنسي
اكد بان التضخم في فرنسا انخفض الى سته
ونصف في المئه في مرسى الحالي
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو الهامليه صحف الصيني اهلا بك
ومن باريس ساندرين مهاوج المحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم
معك سيد الهام في الواقع زياره جد مهمه
لرئيس الفرنسي الى الصين
ونشير الى انه الازمه في اوكرانيا كانت
ثقيله على الاقتصاد الاوروبي عموما
والفرنسي بشكل خاص هل ترى بان الصين قد
تكون بوابه لحل حقيقي لمشاكل الاقتصاد
الفرنسي نعم في الحقيقه يعني باعتبار
الصين شريك مهم لروسيا وايضا شريك مهمه
لكل من فرنسا وايضا الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعتقد هناك دور كبيره بالنسبه للصين لحل
الازمه الاوكرانيه لكن على اساس هناك
تفاهم مشترك من قبل الولايات المتحده او
الدول العربيه وخاصه يعني
لتخلي الولايات المتحده الموقف عدم ثقه
للدور الصيني في حل هذه الازمه خلينا
نتخيل اذا هناك تعاون عسكري بين الصين
وروسيا بعد اندلاء الازمه الاوكرانيه
فماذا يحدث الان اكيد هناك الحرب واسع
نطاقا وحتى ازمه العالميه لكن
الان ما زال ازمه الاوكرانيه ازمه اقليميه
او نقول يعني ازمه عالميه ولكن
بسته قليله جدا هذا الفضل يعود الى موقف
صيني لعدم تقديم الدعم العسكري لروسيا
بشكل مباشر هذا ملف ثاني ولكن لما تقول
سيد الهام بانه الصين قد تكون الحل الحل
كيف قبل ان اذهب الى باريس مع ضيفي الحل
من خلال امكانيه طرح وساطه وان تتعامل
فرنسا معها باكثر ليونه فيما يخص هذه
الوساطه او من خلال الاستثمارات التجاريه
والاقتصاديه اعتقد منا الجانبين طبعا يعني
اول شيء هناك علاقات متينه بين الصين
وروسيا وخاصه يعني كانت الصين تبذل جهودا
متشابه يعني مثل ما لحسنا للحل الازمه
الدبلوماسيه بين مملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران وثاني شيء يعني كان هناك وعد من
قبل الصين
لتقديم المساعدات الاوكرانيه لاعاده
الاعمار وهذا امر مهم جدا هذه النقطه
تقدم الحل من خلال هذه الوساطه بمعنى انها
ستجد نفسها او تفرض على الاوروبيين على
فرنسا بالتحديد
صورتها كوسيط وحيد قادر على حل الازمه ام
ان الصين تفكر بطريقه
عمليه هي تقدم استثمارات وهي تشارك فرنسا
في مختلف ما يمكن ان يستفاد منه الطرفان
مساء الخير طبعا بالنسبه للوضع الراهن
اليوم يعني نتحدث معكم تتحدثين مع الضيف
عن طبيعه الازمه الحاليه في اوكرانيا هل
هي ازمه اقليميه محليه او دوليه الازمه هي
ازمه تدور على ارض اوروبيه بين افريقيا
اوروبيين مباشره ولكن ابعادها الجيو
سياسيه والاقتصاديه طبعا ولكن بشكل اساسي
تقاسم النفوس في العالم واعاده بناء نظام
دولي جديد له ابعاد دوليه شامله وعامه
والصراع هو بشكل مباشر بين قوتين اساسيتين
حكمتها العالم او شكلت
القطبين اساسيان العالم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وزمن الاتحاد السوفيتي وبعده
الان الروسيه لذلك الصين هي قوه صاعده
تريد ان تحتل مكان لها بدرجه الاولى بين
هذين القطبين لتكون هي ربما قطب ثالث ولا
تكون طبعا ان تكون في ظل اي من القطبين
لو سمحت لي فقط اسمح لي فقط على المقاطعه
للتفاعل مع حضرتك فيما حضرتك تعتبرها قوه
صاعده الرئيس ماكرون يعتبر بانه الحل يمكن
ان ياتي من الصين واسمح لي ان نستذكر
مقاله ماكرون خلال هذا التصحيح رئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون يقول بان الصين
قد تمثل هي الحاله الحقيقيه نستمع له
ونعود
[موسيقى]
لقد اثرت الحرب التي قادتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا بشكل عميق على النظام الدولي
الذي عرفناه منذ عام
1945 هذه الحرب انتهكت العديد من مبادئ
ميثاق الامم المتحده والتي يجب علينا
الدفاع عنها بحزم يمكن للصين على وجه
التحديد ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا في حلها
يقول بوضوح يمكن للصين ان تمثل حلا رئيسيا
او طرفا رئيسيا لايجاد حل ما مدى قوه
الصين لطرح هكذا حلوى فرنسا كذلك بان
الصين قادر على فعل ذلك
الكلام كان واضح في الاتصال الهاتفي بين
الرئيس مانويل ماكرون والرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قبل زياره الصين الطرفان اكد على ان
تكون المبادره او الدور الصيني او تكون
الصين شريكه ضمن اطار الافق او النظره او
الرؤيه
التي وضعها الرئيسان من اجل حل مشكله
الصين اي ان تتوافق الصين مع رؤيتهما ومع
شروطهما الشروط الاوروبيه والامريكيه
واضحه في اوكرانيا بالنسبه لمستقبل
اوكرانيا ومستقبل النفوس في المنطقه
الرئيس الصيني لديه مبادره هذه المبادره
حتى الان لم ترى تشق طريقها نحو التنفيذ
لان لدى الرئيس الاوكراني بعد التحفظات
عليها واوروبا وتحدين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقف الى جانبه اذن المبتغى او
المرتجى الاساسي من هذه الزياره كما اعلن
عده مرات هو الحقول دون اقدام الصين على
الوقوف بشكل يعني اكثر دعم لروسيا بالاخص
من خلال تقديم السلاح الاكيد ان الصين لن
تقدم على هذه الخطوه لانها لن تحرق
اوراقها استطاعت حتى الان ان تكون في
مرحله وسط طرفان بحاجه اليها ولكن الصين
تريد ان تكون هي البديل ربما في المستقبل
المبادره الصينيه او الدوله الصيني حتى
الان هو محصور بحد النزاع صحيح ولكن هذا
هو سؤال حضرتك تقول بان الدور الصيني
حاليا مقتصر على الشراكه تجاريه
الاستثماريه الاقتصاديه ولكن يبدو سيد
الهام بان الصين عينها على دور اكبر البعض
يقول بان الصين تخطط للمدى المتوسط الى
البعيد على ان تكون محل او ان تعدد قطبيه
هذا النظام العالمي وان تكون حاضره بقوه
بقوه تضاهي حضور الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل عين الصين على هذا الدور نعم
في الحقيقه هذا ما ساعد الصين في سنوات
الاخيره خاصه مع تقويه القدرات الاقتصاديه
وايضا القطارات العسكريه ولكن حتى الان
يعني من تسريحات من فخامه رئيس الصين
الصين تسعى الى النظام عالمي متعدده
الاقطاب وليس كتب واحد او قطبين مثل ما
لحسنا في سنوات الاخيره واحد هو منذ
السنوات قطب واحد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي التي تدير النظام العالمي هو
تحاول ابتعاد عن وجوع الازمات الاوكرانيه
وخاصه المواجهات العسكريه ولكن من كان
يريد الحرب او الازمات كانت الولد
الولايات المتحده تسع لتحريض كل من روسيا
والدول الاوروبيه يعني بشكل خاص الصين لم
تكن تدفع بذلك وكانت تود ان يكون هناك
اطار اخر للحديد
سيد هل فرنسا نعلم
تفضل تفضل
فقط كنت اريد ان اقول بان الصين الان هي
تريد ان تعطي نفسها دور الوسيط ولكن
بالواقع لن تستطيع ان تكون هذا الوسيط لو
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لديه رغبه بتدخل ما
من دوله غير دول الصراع من اجل الخروج من
هذا المازق هل هذه الازمه التي ايضا تنعكس
على اوروبا ضررا يجب ان لا ننسى ان الصين
هي في حاله صراع مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لها
دور اساسي في اوكرانيا اذا عندما يكون
طرفان في صراع مباشره على موضوع تايوان
على موضوع التجاري في المستقبل على موضوع
منطقه ايران والشرق الاوسط كل هذه هي نقاط
خلاف وسيراء مع الصين بل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من جهه
والصين اذا كيف يمكن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مثلا ان تقبل او ان تساهم او ان
تؤيد الصين تسعى لانجاح دور الصين في
اوكرانيا اذا كانت معها في مناطق اخرى لا
تريد ان تكون الصين صحيح الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن تقبل ولكن اوروبا قادره ان
تقبل فرنسا قادره ان تقبل اليوم الارقام
مفزعه اليوم نتحدث في فرنسا على معدل تضخم
فقط لنستذكر بعض الارقام لانه هناك واقع
معدل تضخم بلغ 5.2% في 2022 بعد 1.6
بالمئه عام 2021 اسعار الطاقه ارتفعت
بنسبه 23,1 بالمئه واسعار الاغذيه ارتفعت
بنسبه 6.8 الارقام مرعبه قد تستر ماكرون
للقبول كذلك ببعض التفاصيل
الرئيس الفرنسي لنفهم معنى زيارته في
العمق هناك طبعا الواجهه والحديث الاساسي
عن موضوع اوكرانيا والحرب ودور الصين ولكن
لننظر الى الوفد الذي يرافق الرئيس
الفرنسي ليس وفدا سياسيا ولا امنيا لديه
وفد من رجال اعمال ومدراء شركاء من حوالي
اربعين شركه فرنسيه في مجال الطيران تعاون
في مجال الطيران ايرباص مثلا في مجال
الطاقه والطاقه النوويه ونظيفه في مجال
البيئه في كل هذه الاطارات يسعى رئيس
الفرنسي من خلال هذه الزياره هناك حديث
طبعا عن اوكرانيا عن حقوق الانسان عن
منطقه الشرق الاوسط عن كل قضايا العالم
طبعا ولكن الهدف الاساسي الذي يريد مكرونه
يحققه هو التوقيع على هذه الاتفاقات
التبادل التجاري بين الصين بين الصين
وفرنسا ارتفع اسمح لي على المقاطعه
واعذتني والاكيد باننا سنبقى
ولكن سيد اندري التوقيت انتهى تماما
سامحني واعذرني ن في لقاءات اخرى شكرا
جزيلا لك على الحضور وعلى المشاركه من
باريس ساندرين هاوج المحلل السياسي شكرا
والمعذره مره اخرى وفي الاستوديو الهام لي
صحفي الصيني شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]